hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today is Tuesday it is October 16th
marching fire release comes with
everything the Wulin characters the
breach mode the weapons the graphical
enhancements the voice lines everything
is coming out today so as usual of
course your boys gonna have a video let
me find some JJ in the breach mode first
match I played the audio cut out and I
could not hear anything the second time
I played the loading screen was infinite
I sat in there for maybe more than five
minutes so third time's a charm and
hopefully we can actually start playing
but yeah either way guys like the v4 do
enjoy subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of fauna that being
balance changes hero updates patch notes
leaks all that good stuff as well some
gameplay as well and I'll see you guys
when the match actually starts and the
match has finally begun I believe we are
on the defending team it looks like yeah
we're the blue team so we are defending
the attacking team of course is
attacking us we're gonna be I believe
what is this the samurai
I haven't [ __ ] losing oh it's the
night we're on the Viking map but it's
at the night time and for the teams of
course we hit get stuck with a bot and
to tea on bees in the Jang Joon versus a
bot and of course the enemy team decided
to bring the remains to the cannon
fodder of the first day of release so we
have a rep 16 shoe goki rep 53 conquer
and a repla 20 awarded so I don't expect
to be getting very many kills this King
won because I hate all three of those
characters actually I don't really hate
you go key too much but it's also the
fact that I'm playing a literal new
character so we're gonna gang up on the
bottom hopefully get some damage
throws me to the fire goddamn gotta
gotta remember that the breech guys do a
decent amount of damage I have to stay
away from them trying to get too deep
okay Perry I thought I'd got broke that
should go if you get to try to throw
something through a heavy and a conch
through is heavy at the same time and
clapped me yeah I'm gonna try to be
cutting some of this stuff out since the
respawns in this game take literal like
half a minute like 30 seconds sometimes
so I'm gonna try to cut those up there's
no reason for you to be staring at my
screen for 30 seconds so hopefully
you're just gonna be seeing just
straight action or me dying
I don't know first game of the day first
time playing this character in a month
and it's also against guys who are
really good at their character so we'll
see nice kill T on D hit him with the I
hit him with the shin kick that helped a
bit shego keys on the shield that's not
good I did the other statement or wrong
because I'm bad that's also the one
thing I need to remember is the out of
stamina punishes for all the stuff I'm
gonna have to look back at my little
PowerPoint that I have or my little
notes to remember I also forgot to
mention not only does it suck that the
enemy team also has really high rep guys
go since this is a gear stats focused
type game-mode they have obviously have
the better stats than us more knowledge
of the character and they have better
perks than us so that's not really good
right now it's not a good sign really
sucks that I have to go against these
guys in the first game or technically
first game but I'm not stressing too
much I had a feeling it was gonna happen
get a minion they're still gonna show
bash me to oblivion that's gonna be fun
thankfully Cheon Dee saved me there cuz
I probably would have died because he
would have guard broke me come here boy
you know you ain't gettin away from me
that was a crazy weird that was a weird
play I do have my first feet now and
that I believed helps my teammates do
more I think it's either me or my whole
teammates or just a combination of both
of us the more enemies that are around
me so we're gonna try to keep it that
way I try to get into these team fights
as best as I can go keys running away
probably good thing for him you don't
want none of this fat love no I'm gonna
go back down I see my teammates and help
all right
need some help shouldn't have done that
forgot it's a zone Dan that's gonna hurt
me I'm so deadly
Oh your boy is so screwed right now
damn the minions are cooking through my
revenge as well it's not good
all the men you killed me dan hit him
beautiful stuff Dion D I do a big clear
here
activate see Fu's poised like it start
clearing quicker see now now that we're
here the minions are still here but now
that we're here we're dumbing it down to
one arrow now it's fully stopped since
all the minions are gone and now this
catapult will not move for the entire D
you know while we're still sitting here
what we should have been doing though is
watching the archer towers now that
those are captured which suck we have to
watch out for those yeah let me know how
you guys have been enjoying breach if
you have the update of the update the
downloaded and stuff like that mine of
course took me a bit to download but
I've been having a lot of fun with it
and also let me know what other
characters you guys want me to play
honestly I've been enjoying Jang Joon
but I don't know if I really want to
stick with him I haven't really decided
on a we'll call it a main per se I'm
still kind of that is a really [ __ ]
slow catapult I forgot that nerve that
yeah they nerf that catapult heavy in
this update yeah I'm not really sure who
I should main in terms of like the
characters of the Wulin I don't really
know honestly so if you guys have like
any recommendations I'll totally be down
I've been taking about JJ I've been
thinking about Shaolin also a little bit
about T on D since it just does not many
it seems like now many people have been
wanting to play him on the YouTube side
of things so I thought I could maybe
fill that gap I wasn't really big on
Musha I just don't like her boy style I
think she's very trash she needs to be
buffed or something cuz I don't like the
way that she operates as a character her
trap can easily be dodged and whatnot
it's just not a fun she's not I find her
not as enjoyable to play as she should
be
well let's go man with the seafood
poised twice in a row man this is some
top tier gameplay not really
yeah just if you guys have any ideas I'd
love to know honestly I'm down for
literally any character I find except
new show not no hate on new shoes bro
just a personal thing to me I just don't
find her enjoyable but I find the other
three completely enjoyable as well
yeah I'm honestly though like James
Jones zone is really nice according to
some rankings people have been saying
that he is like third in terms of like
score
I shouldn't say score a lot of people
think that James June is like the third
like worst character or go third place
out of the four factions room I don't
really see it though I find him to be
actually very fun I definitely do not
think he's top tier I definitely think
tea on D is the best character in of the
Wulin
but I feel like James Jude is pretty
pretty good personally Shaolin III would
definitely take him as I could see him
being number two but you know that could
be debatable depending on the type of
Shaolin player or James Jun player and I
just got absolutely [ __ ] destroyed by
that that shoulder bastard damn I was
going for that parry now bro you're not
won in this game you're not winning this
out of stamina game bro not at all
and he caught that one didn't you always
got shield basher or whatever that's
cold if I'm correct like a Perry in my
Chokin right now
get that minute miniature damage yeah
I've 100% just [ __ ] revenged in a 1v1
no shame I have no shame I'm [ __ ]
garbage but I have no shame with that at
all
I do have all my feats which is crazy I
actually have no clue what half of these
do one of these is a passive I think it
gives energy one of these has to do with
stamina one of these is a healing thing
I think it's in the order from left to
right
I think it's damage stamina health and
then the fire thing which does like fire
damage if I get near them or like if I
place it near them I don't know though I
actually have no clue I'll check in a
bit once I've finished this you go key
or died of this you go key that should
be a zone okay it was still good though
he was a hit rock steady so I didn't
waste that I was I was worried man now
that I have a static guard it feels
great to play against or just [ __ ]
stat or shoot me but that's that feels
bad yeah let me check out these feats
real quick we have against all odds'
nearby allies deal more damage than more
enemies don't run that's a teamfight
passive nearby allies benefit from
seafoods poise oh so when I activate
seafoods poise my mice their stamina
their stamina is a lot better I believe
and then soothing mist is heal allies an
area of effects that's good and then
fiery barrage loose fiery sparks behind
the target that stuns all enemies who
cross it that's good
gave him the stun and I popped the hell
for the fellow Valkyrie player so that
she can just live a little longer
fire Braj didn't do exactly what I
wanted but I'll gladly take that and
there goes the catapult with its 2,000
millisecond timing that's actually
absurd how bad that is although it kind
of feels like it was a needed nerf I
don't think they should have done it
this bad this was a crazy nerf to it I
need to get away from the Chicago key
but good parry on him he's gonna let me
drop that that's fine once you get hit
with it though you do drop it
immediately C on D help me out here
buddy Dan this is no good that's fine
almost pull off the execution I didn't
know he I was gonna do that I was just
hoping I was just assuming he's gonna
carry it yeah also with this new update
all the minions now they get rid of your
revives executions like that type of
stuff I mean before minions you could
just literally heal an opponent through
the minions and they wouldn't do
anything they would do minor damage to
you but they really wouldn't do anything
now minions and all game modes are
affected by this so I mean I'm assuming
the breach guys of course they're big in
wielding and stuff but
there goes their ghost should go key
easy hit ward it now has revenge
interesting so right now if you look in
the top they have ten lives and two of
them are going to respawn soon that's
gonna be at means they're gonna have
eight but now the word said that means I
have seven lives left
see this Noguchi just before was like
clapping me and getting em parrying
everything but now she can't block
anything so we're gonna feel up the
squad real quick and pull out the Buffs
get the heels all the buffs are coming
out this round we're going apeshit boys
no where to run from big thick guy here
give no chance get out of my face good
clap easy double kill
nice stuff buff seem to come in handy
real quickly and games getting to a
close they've barely touched our Lord
gonna get an execution at the end here
standard one chop off the head eight
seconds there's no time that's gonna be
a gg for our team but we're gonna
increase our win our win count here
we're gonna quit increase our chances a
bit and they ran out of time it's a good
fight that's a win I was expecting to
lose that was impressive and we're gonna
do the signature nice beautiful stuff
beautiful stuff yeah guys it's going to
be the end of the vid I hope you guys
did enjoy think as for watching the
video hope you guys did enjoy some of
the Jang Joon gameplay and stuff like
that like I said I'd be down to playing
the other character like to Gandhi
Shaolin or Jang Joon still don't really
know my main for this game but I'm kind
of leaning toward JJ here but who knows
that might change in the future
hey guys like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational site or phone or that big
balance changes here are updates patch
notes leaks all that good stuff all the
news of for honor and did some gameplay
as well if you're watching this the day
that this goes live be aware tonight I
most likely will be streaming this game
so y'all can hop in when we play some
breach there you know I'll watch chill
all that good stuff but yeah guys take
care my to most viewers would be on
screen if you guys so check that okay
guys have a great rest err day enjoy
marching fire breach and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]